el perímetro de la figura es de 24
centímetros
wilders la longitud del lado que falta
entonces nos dicen que esta figura de
aquí tiene un perímetro de 24
centímetros aquí dice el perímetro es de
24 centímetros lo que quiere decir que
la distancia de todo el borde exterior
es de 24 centímetros pero lo que
nosotros queremos saber es cuál es la
longitud del lado que falta del lado que
falta y bueno justo el lado que falta es
este que estoy remarcando ahorita este
es el lado que nos falta porque observa
que tenemos aquí un signo de
interrogación es decir es el único lado
que no está etiquetado entonces lo que
queremos saber es
en número hay que poner aquí en este
lado faltante para que el perímetro de
toda la figura sea de 24 centímetros
bien así que empecemos lo primero que
quiero que veas es que este lado
superior este lado de acá arriba tiene
una longitud de 6 centímetros así que
vamos a empezar con el él tiene una
longitud de 6 centímetros por lo tanto
aquí voy a escribir 6 centímetros más y
vamos a sumar todos los lados y ahora si
le sumamos también este lado que tenemos
a la izquierda este lado de aquí que es
de 5 centímetros vamos a tener 6 + 5 ya
esto le voy a sumar ahora el lado que
tengo en la parte inferior que se
observa tiene una longitud de 4
centímetros + 4 ya esto le vamos a sumar
este otro lado que tengo aquí este otro
lado de 4 centímetros también
4 centímetros lo voy a escribir aquí y
si a todo esto le sumamos la longitud
del lado que falta la longitud del lado
que falta esto nos va a dar el perímetro
esto va a ser igual al perímetro que
sabemos que es 24 centímetros es decir
que la suma de todas las distancias de
cada uno de los lados 65 + 44 más la
longitud del lado el misterioso eso nos
va a dar un perímetro de 24 centímetros
así que vamos a sumarlos y ver si
podemos encontrar el valor del lado
faltante ya mí me gusta mucho hacer
dieces y cómo podemos sumar en cualquier
orden vamos a sumar primero 6
+ 4 lo cual me va a dar 10 y ahora 10 5
me va a dar 15 y 15 4 me va a dar 19
entonces sabemos que 19 más la longitud
de este lado misterioso tiene que ser
igual a 24 esto tiene que ser igual a 24
y bueno ya sabemos de dónde vienen 19
centímetros de este borde de esta figura
son los 19 centímetros de todo este
borde de color azul así que cuantos
centímetros más debe de tener este lado
faltante para que podamos tener una
longitud total del borde de toda la
figura de 24 centímetros bueno podemos
hacer esta operación 19 más 1 es lo
mismo que 20 y 20 más 4 nos da 24
entonces uno para veinte y cuatro más
para veinticuatro eso quiere decir que
este lado faltante tiene que tener una
longitud de 5 centímetros nos da un
total de 5 centímetros más así que este
lado que nos falta debe de tener una
longitud de 5 centímetros para que el
perímetro de toda la figura sea de 24
centímetros y ya está así que vamos a
resolver un ejercicio más y para eso voy
a quitar este problema y vamos a traer
por acá
el siguiente problema bien y dice el
perímetro de un rectángulo es de 32
metros sabemos que uno de sus lados mide
11 metros
cuál es la longitud del lado que falta y
otra vez de nuevo tenemos un lado
faltante
así que qué te parece si dibujamos por
aquí un rectángulo para que sea mucho
más fácil visualizar este problema y
bueno sabemos que uno de sus lados miden
11 metros es justo lo que dice este
problema uno de sus lados mide 11 metros
así que lo voy a poner aquí 11 metros y
bueno también sabemos que es un
rectángulo y los rectángulos cumplen que
sus lados opuestos son iguales
así que si este es 11 metros este de
aquí también tendrá una longitud de 11
metros
bien esto es lo que sabemos pero no
sabemos cuánto vale este lado de acá
arriba es justo lo que nos falta y
tampoco sabemos cuánto vale este lado de
abajo este que tenemos acá abajo ambos
son los lados faltantes así que cuál es
su longitud bueno de nuevo sabemos que
el perímetro es de 32 metros eso es lo
que nos dice el problema entonces la
pregunta se va a ver de la siguiente
manera si sumamos 11 metros de esta
longitud que tengo aquí en estos 11
metros los sumamos
a los siguientes 11 metros de esta otra
longitud que tengo aquí esta que tengo
aquí más otros 11 metros ya esto le
sumamos la longitud de este lado que es
la longitud que buscamos ya esto le
sumamos la longitud de este otro lado
que por cierto es el mismo número
misterioso es el mismo número misterioso
y esto se debe a que la longitud de
estos dos lados son iguales si sumamos
estos cuatro lados nos tienen que dar el
perímetro y el perímetro es de 32 metros
porque recuerda es la distancia total
que debe de tener el borde del
rectángulo así que primero sumemos 11 11
11 11 es lo mismo que 22 así que lo voy
a poner aquí 22 más y bueno tenemos dos
lados misteriosos más un lado misterioso
más otro lado misterioso esto tiene que
ser igual a 32 tiene que ser igual a 32
y ahora si tenemos 22 que tenemos que
sumarle para que nos dé 32 bueno 22 más
es lo mismo que 32 pero hay que tener
cuidado porque si queremos etiquetar
cada uno de los lados restantes y si
pusiéramos 10 en uno de estos lados
entonces el otro tendría que ser 0 así
que esto no es posible porque queremos
dos lados iguales por lo tanto como
divido diez metros en dos longitudes
iguales para estos dos lados
bueno la mitad de 10 es 5 así que 22 más
+ 5 es lo mismo que 32 aquí también voy
a poner 5 y 5 esto quiere decir que cada
uno de estos lados debe de medir 5
metros y este también 5 metros porque 22
más 55 es igual a 32 22 más 10 es 32
entonces la longitud del lado que falta
es de 5 metros y ya con esto acabamos